il y a des moments je veux dire un petit
peu dangereux
il respecte le code de la route
[Musique]
là encore tout commence sur la butte on
connaît tous la célèbre de chevaux et
bien 30 millions d'amis à trouver dans
Paris un équipage extraordinaire la
formule de chien un vélo séparait-il la
voiture de l'avenir pour les temps de
crise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais regardez plutôt en effet Monsieur
Perrini ancien ouvrier tourneur
aujourd'hui à la retraite parcourt en de
longues promenades journalières les rues
de la capitale accompagnées de ces deux
superbes chiens
[Musique]
à côté
les animaux le père et le fils sont
d'une remarquable obéissance ainsi
depuis des années que le manège dur ils
n'ont provoqué aucun accident la
circulation grâce à leur sang-froid et
tout épreuve certains seront peut-être
intrigués par la race de ces deux beaux
animaux et bien sachez que ce serait un
mélange lointain de loups et de malinois
le berger belge bien connu originaire du
Pays d'Eddy Merckx tout s'explique
[Musique]
l'écurie Périgny un rêve secret une
bonne crise de l'énergie pensée des rues
vidées de leur voiture et des milliers
de bicyclettes amis parcourant la
capitale dans un grand silence enfin il
reste d'autres plaisirs comme par
exemple les rencontres imprévues
[Musique]
le passage le plus cabreux de cette
nouvelle version de la traversée de
Paris et sans nul doute celui de la
Place de l'Étoile pour l'équipage c'est
le grand cirque le problème est bien sûr
de respecter la priorité mais surtout de
ne pas attirer l'attention des gardiens
de la paix qui regardent le manège d'un
œil amusé et sceptique
[Musique]
enfin les grands espaces verts de la
capitale nous attend ce qu'il y a de
surprenant dans cette nouvelle formule
de promenade c'est qu'on a l'impression
que Monsieur Perini a complètement
oublié qu'il était dans une ville
asphyxiée par l'automobile il serait en
rase campagne qu'il ne changerait rien
[Applaudissements]
qui a montré un petit peu à César
comment ça se passait
comment se prête les automobilistes à ce
petit manège
moi ça va et tout le monde le respecte
et les gens de la police parisienne
et vous faites ça d'une seule traite ou
quoi orange
tous les jours oui même quand il pleut
il y a des moments je veux dire un petit
peu dangereux là
parce que moi j'ai toujours fait du vélo
et puis
j'aime les chiens avec moi c'est tout
difficile que ça
bon ben écoutez on va continuer notre
petit promenade allez-y monsieur
c'est reparti certaines fois cette noble
escort fait un détour par l'Elysée là
les gardes républicains qui ont pour
mission de veiller sur le char de l'État
sont toujours étonnés de voir passer ce
curieux équipage
[Applaudissements]
enfin pour clore cette belle journée et
pour se désaltérer l'écurie Périgny
seront à brides à la brasserie au chien
qui fume de Montparnasse
[Musique]
après les recommandations de sagesse
donnée à Atos le père Monsieur Perini va
se désaltérer
[Musique]
les chiens ont bien mérité aussi
quelques breuvages des dieux
[Musique]
mais il arrive parfois que même étant un
chien modèle on souhaite un peu porter
sur la bouteille et que l'on se retrouve
les pâtes coupées et la vue double tout
le problème alors c'est de remonter sur
la butte mais c'est déjà une autre
histoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]